are you doing today sir I'm good man
good to see you nice to see you um I'm
gonna start with I would imagine that
working with Peter Berg and Mark
Wahlberg was [ __ ] cool yeah right so
what maybe surprised you about making
working with the two of them that maybe
you weren't expecting um I don't know if
I was surprised I just had my own
challenges and figuring out my own way
and my own language to fit into their
pre-existing mode of working because
they have such a shorthand so you got to
like establish your own way and I was
like how do I cut through and make my my
own space in this and one of the things
I did was I went back and watched all
that like Peter Berg's movies and I
remember it in lone survivor I loved Ben
Foster it's one of my favorite actors
and I remembered him and in lone
survivor he was quiet but I always
remembered finding him anytime he was on
screen and I thought what is it about
this character that's still able to cut
through all the frenetic and kinetic
energy and it was his stillness so I
wanted to kind of bring a bit of that
stillness and thought into this film and
that's like how I worked on developing
hawk I was like I wanted Hawk to always
feel present always feel like he's
thinking and is aware of his
surroundings and that you'll always pick
him up because there's a clear
juxtaposition to all the action and
movement and momentum that's going on in
the film I would imagine every time you
make a project you never know what
you're gonna be shooting on the first
day what do you typically like to shoot
on the first day and what did you shoot
on the first day of this I actually came
with so many things this movie was
everywhere
and we were doing so much it was always
something new and the thing about Peter
is he has like four or five cameras
going I think one of the first things
were was that in the gym
boxing where I picked the guy up and I
slam him on the ground
and we're doing like the UFC kind of H
fighting and peter has all these cameras
going on and it's really real so he'll
just throw something at you in the MoMA
and as you're figuring out what you're
gonna do and how you want to go about it
he's capturing you so it always feels
you know super documentarian in that way
you know completely yeah I of course
have to ask you before I run out of time
have you spoken to Ryan do you know if
you're a black panther - I don't know a
thing man and you have all the
experience with this they don't say
anything they're tight-lipped from top
to bottom so I'm gonna find out when you
find out or when marble makes some sort
of press release yeah exactly um so what
am i we've spoken we spoke for nine days
before I saw the movie and now that I've
seen the movie it was one of my favorite
films at Sundance Thank You Man for and
I believe you executive produced it yeah
so for people that have only heard the
title and are not really familiar with
it yet like what can you tease people
about it and because I know it you know
that there was a very strong reaction by
a lot of people of course a the film was
received incredibly well we won one of
the Grand Jury prizes at Sundance
and it is about a man with a very
particular job in the afterlife his job
is to interview spirits for the
opportunity to be born and that's what
I'll give you it's a heavy concept but
it's executed very simply and very
direct and it's a beautiful conversation
and celebration of life 100% yes yeah
it's one of those do you know I believe
Sony picked it up for Sony Pictures
Classics is our partner and distribution
on this bad boy and they're they're the
right people they know how to curate
conversation and it's one of those
conversational pieces it's one of those
pizzas that I think audiences aren't
always aware that they wanted it until
they get it and they see it yet do you
have any idea when people might see a
trailer or when it might become it's
coming where we're figuring out what to
do with it but it's it's coming on we're
super excited it's gonna land and we
hope that people love it you know
completely jumping one last question on
Spencer I would imagine this was an
awesome experience what's like a dare -
that you will always remember from
shooting day or two others couples so
first off that day with the big truck
scene and seeing that happen and just
like seeing the scope of that
and being blown away by it and all the
guns and everything the cameras roaring
it was just so like I said kinetic and
and wild and then there's a scene where
we go to sissy's house and all the dogs
are in the house and it literally was
about 40 dogs forty dogs in a house and
Peter Berg is on a god Mike and he's
like get the dogs face get the dog's
face I want to get in his eyes I want to
know what that dog's thinking see what
that dogs thinking right now get hawk
and I'm like whoa what wasn't everyone's
just like it's going when that
documentary style is happening and
everything is real everything's real so
like you get all that like kinetic
phonetic energy that like feeds the pace
and makes it such a beautiful experience
and Peter you know he's he's a genius he
knows what he's doing he puts it all
together and there's a level of like
foresight to know how everything's gonna
come together so that's what that was
one of my favorite days cuz I'm a big
dog lover I just I just don't own a pet
so I'm like feeling like I own things